what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are continuing on with
invincible Iron Man and it's actually
kind of cool I mean I'm pretty excited
about this because this is basically the
return of Tony Stark but it's one of
these things where you can tell that
Bendis had somewhat set the stage for
what was supposed to come after this now
whether or not it was the plan of
benders to do this and they continue
writing and then ultimately jump ship
and head over to DC Comics where the
ships not sinking then you know we don't
we don't really know like we don't know
that's if that's the case or not
um at this point it's just kind of like
then to set it up for things to come
after this so in reality it's really
kind of like anybody's guess on what
direction things going but initially
this picks up really with parker robbins
now again we talked about in the last
video the Parker Robbins the hood has
really kind of been on this campaign to
try to take out Victor Von Doom now we
didn't initially know why this was the
case instead it was basically Parker
Robbins kind of reforming the sort of
modern-day masters of evil more or less
using some pretty low-level thugs and
then launching these little you know
small-time attacks against Doctor Doom
only for us to find out that the reason
why he's doing this is because his goal
is to basically steal the gold in
Latveria that's essentially the goal of
parker robbins here is to steal gold in
liberia it's a pretty primitive goal but
then again Parker Robbins was never
really that great of a villain in the
first place and so it's one of the cool
things it actually goes on here's one of
the interesting situations what we end
up finding out is that one of the guys
he's brought along a guy by the name of
corruptor has the ability to basically
create these kind of psycho is this sort
of psychoactive effect in the mind to
force people to see like hallucinations
or the have the body reacted in an
exceedingly violent way but he can only
do it through like physical contact but
it's kind of a cool thing because then
at this point we switch over to twenty
Stark now remember Tony Stark you know
despite the fact that he's kind of
resurrected himself more or less in like
a new body basically uh he's been having
these hallucinations you know with
regards to like members of the superhero
community and even his own family and in
this instance he has a hallucination of
his dad now in reality this is really
more of like a subconscious concept
working its way to the conscious mind
and then him basically dealing with it
specifically with regards to the fact
that he was adopted because this was a
concept that Tony Stark never really
dealt with proper and this sense of like
he knew that he was adopted but he never
really was able to come to terms with
his father about it because his father
was dead but in this moment when he's
kind of going through this sort of
hallucinogenic state when his mind
sort of restructuring itself and when
his body is physically recovering he
kind of has this internal argument with
his father about the fact that you know
he never told me I was a dog to
different things like that but a really
cool points made here is that Howard
Stark basically says well the fact that
you're adopted is here relevant like
you're still my son
like I raised you as my son I taught you
everything you know I left you an empire
heel I am his good ass and in reality
it's true while Tony Stark is a doctor
the fact that Howard Stark taught him
everything he needed to know about what
it meant to be a man to be successful to
build on his intelligence those are the
only things that really matter you know
his father was never in his life his
father was never there to teach him
those lessons Howard Stark was the one
who was and so really if if Tony hadn't
been told that he was adopted everything
would still stand everything would still
be the same so there really is no
difference here between Howard and the
actual father of Tony but the actual
father of Tony wool will make it
appearance here in Lowell law now
something else has been going on here is
that Friday has basically been kind of
subverting her programming to a degree
and going through and like hunting down
or trying to trace down the location of
Tony Stark which they were ultimately
successful in doing it was actually an
old shield bunker so again kind of
hitting back at the old Nick Fury era of
comics where he always had these safe
houses but when they get in there they
end up finding this the armor that Tony
Stark was in but he's basically outside
of his army now he's essentially left
and so it's kind of cool because he's
out there doing his own thing presumably
trying to find a way to come back now
another funny little caveat here this is
kind of wild is what is up happening is
that while Ruby Williams is pondering
the idea of walking away because Oliver
Tech was basically taken by Stark
Industries by the Board of Board of
Trustees when she's sitting there
basically mulling over the idea of
returning to MIT she's met with the
arrival of blade now apparently blade
works for shield I have no idea it's
been 15 years as I read a blade comic so
I can't tell you what the world blades
been doing all this and all this time I
mean I remember him from the movie and
that's it like this
I am I am I know almost nothing about
blade anything has happened in the last
15 years I don't know but she ultimately
ends up basically traveling back to MIT
now when she does what we end up finding
out here is that there are a handful of
people who are basically trying to track
down Tony Stark in addition to riri
williams herself one of them is tony ho
actually the the daughter of yinsen ho
the person that helped Tony Stark build
the mark 1 when he was kidnapped in
Vietnam and then the other one oh really
though that the you know there's a
couple others but one of them
arno start now if I'm being honest here
I don't really like the way that bindus
handles are no story he's just kind of
like a guy who's there and that's what I
disappointing because those of you guys
who read Karen Gillan's run of Ironman
autostart played a huge role the idea of
him you basically know after being
revealed that Arno is the actual
biological son of Howard and Maria that
he's basically smarter than Tony Stark
you know that he's kind of reduced here
just being a guy who needs the help of
Ruby Williams in order to crack a code
it's kind of weird because it's like
saying like Reed Richards can't figure
something out on his own and so he has
to go to iron man to do it
I mean you're talking about one of the
smartest people on the planet so the
fact that autostart would need anybody
is a little mind boggling here so it's a
little weird to me but again it does
give a pretty cool role to RiRi in the
sense that she asked something to
contribute here but at this point we
basically end up dealing with iron man
being more or less defeated by Parker
Robbins now it's really more of a
smaller thing but this whole situation
basically has them traveling back to
Liberia and then basically Parker Robins
arriving with this huge you know army of
street-level thugs basically and then
all of them using their various powers
to take down Doctor Doom is Iron Man now
it's kind of a funny thing here because
Bennis is somewhat playing on the idea
that Doctor Doom is you know
quote-unquote reformed right I mean if
this was classic Doctor Doom from like
Fantastic Four annual number two or
number four lawyers uh he would have
just made short work of he would just
kill them all and that would have been
the end of it he would have been like
you're done but he guys are all dead but
the fact that he's kind of trying to
turn over a new leaf trying to do the
right thing uh basically means that it's
a way for them to subvert his power ah
to essentially overcome him and then in
turn to feed him now some of it's also
because of the fact that there's just so
many people there they just basically
overwhelm him the problem with this is
that once they manage to get through
they manage to essentially like break
into his armor he's gone he's basically
teleported out and so that information
is basically gone with him and so again
it's essentially Parker Robins kind of
sitting around and saying okay in order
for us to find the location of the gold
in Liberia we have to track down to any
Stark because that's where Doctor Doom
is gonna go he's gonna go fine Tony so
again it's kind of like this mad rush
everybody's looking to find Tony Stark
now switching back to blade what we end
up finding out here is that in this
whole situation what it basically
happened is he had gone to Ruby Williams
and said a lot of people are looking for
a Tony Stark or at least what used to be
so it's not really shield anymore after
secret empire but it's like a lot of
people are looking for Tony Stark
you need to go to MIT because there are
people there that will help you find
Tony which of course now we know is or
no and and and Tony Howe and so on and
so forth but with them basically
banning together and then going to seek
out Tony what is up happening is Friday
software is totally corrupted and she's
basically possessed by Tony Stark
himself who literally says stop looking
for me like I have things I need to take
care of stop trying to track me down
like let me go do my thing and then I
will come and find you when the time is
right and so it's kind of a cool moment
here it's a cool little segment to see
the Tony Stark despite the fact that he
is believed to have been dead or at the
very least he's operating on bare-bones
tech is still able to outclass almost
everybody there now what Tony actually
ends up doing is traveling directly to
meet his mother basically say hey look
there's a few things that I'm sorting
out here but it's kind of cool because
that's this you know the connection
between the two of them is pretty strong
remember they've only recently met each
other and so it's like the one thing
Tony's been trying to figure out is how
to get back to his mom and say hey look
here's where things stand everything's
okay she's kind of freaked out that he's
bald a little bit and he's like well you
know I mean I basically resurrected
myself in a new body so you know that
happens but what Tony does is also throw
her microphone of sorts and say like
tell me about my biological father now
this is the first real indication we
actually get about this the idea of Tony
Stark's biological father was neither
hide nor hear you didn't see anything
about it and even actually like the his
biological mom here you know Amanda we
didn't see anything about that until
like international iron so it was a few
years after the the introduction of the
idea that Tony was adopted before we
ever even saw any real expansion on it
now a lot of that was because Karen
Gillan took off he basically left and
went to go do his own thing but it is an
interesting scenario because what we end
up finding out here is that the father
of Tony Stark was a SHIELD agent who
turned Hydra and he actually started
selling out shield agents to Hydra and
it's interesting I'm not a hundred
percent sure how I feel about that but
again it's kind of a cool situation
because what it does is it creates a
potential enemy for Tony you know in the
sense that like what was his father
doing what were the kind of things that
he was getting into so on and so forth
and then the plot gets even crazier this
is the problem with Indus riding is
occasionally he'll just go off the
reservation but this is actually pretty
cool in the middle of their attempt to
find Tony Stark riri Williams Tony how
all those guys are met with the arrival
of Leonardo da Vinci
now on the surface people are just kind
of like okay this is ridiculous and
maybe it is to a degree but recently
watch it going all the way back Jonathan
Hickman started I think it was Jonathan
and Nick Trudeau - oh I remember who it
was it actually drew it they lost a
series called shield and it was a
miniseries that they went for issues and
there was unfinished for like seven
years or something
like that and recently five issues five
and six were finished but that was
basically the story of like the origin
of shield and Leonardo da Vinci was a
member of a group called the Brotherhood
of the shield which was the precursor to
shield itself and so there were a whole
lot of things that took place they were
the first ones to fight clientís they
were the first ones to repel the
Celestials there were a lot of different
things that were going on there was a
lot of changing that was going on in the
realm of Marvel Comics and it's a really
really cool story we might cover at some
point is actually pretty awesome dealing
with all that history in the Marvel
Universe but again what we also end up
finding out here is that where Amanda
Armstrong at basically told Tony looked
like I killed your father essentially is
what happened your father turned out to
be a Hydra agent and I killed him to
protect you we end up finding out that
his father is actually alive and it's
cool here because again what this means
this could play a very very very big
role in the life of Twente start
tracking down as Hydra agent father now
this also follows up with Tony trying to
make amends and trying to fix things
essentially by resurrecting James Rhodes
now with James Rhodes being brought back
with his mind simply being downloaded
into like a new consciousness of sorts
things just kind of pick up as if they
never stopped in the sense that my James
Rhodes essentially has all the memories
of everything that happened even the
fact that he was killed by Thanos but we
also kind of end up doing is you know
with James Rhodes being resurrected is a
chance for him and Tony Stark to meet
over Tony Stark to also sort of get him
back in gear get him ready to be war
machine and then we switch back over to
Leonardo da Vinci now the fact that
Leonardo da Vinci helped to establish
shield he kind of gives us a sort of
backstory and simply saying that like
he's been watching from the shadows the
entire time and we're shield was
basically corrupted where he was
essentially brought down by by Steve
Rogers and were shielded kind of grown
into this sort of unwieldly unruly giant
massive intelligence organization that
could have presumably brought everything
crashing down which ultimately ended up
happening in secret empire that shield
did not maintain its original charter to
be a protector of all life on earth
that's really the original basis behind
his formation by Leonardo da Vinci and a
handful of others and so because of this
da Vinci has kind of gone back and sort
of reworked what shield is supposed to
be not in the sense that he's recreated
it but in the sense that he's kind of
making something akin to it but it is
kind of cool because like Miles Morales
for example is brought in it's really
kind of like a veritable who's who of
people who have dealt with Iron Man or
who were exceedingly smart or capable in
their own right there's a variety of
reasons of you know for why people are
being brought in here but the fact
remains that what we end up basically
doing is picking up with Parker robbers
we
learning that with him going after Tony
Stark in order to be Doctor Doom there
and then basically realizing that Tony
Stark is missing and that the the Board
of Directors essentially you know Eric
Lynch is trying to go through and seize
control of the company
Parker Robin sees it as a means to rule
directly what Parker Robbins does is he
basically approaches Eric Lynch and he's
like I could smell like Howard from a
mile away and you are certainly a coward
and so the idea is I've got a gun to
your head you're gonna give me power of
attorney over like your whole position
and so you're gonna step down I will
step into your role and then I will run
Stark Industries it's it's actually a
genius idea now of course but what do
you have James Rhodes and then you have
Tony Stark respond as well as Doctor
Doom Iron Man all showing up at the same
time it's like this massive conflict
against the forces of Parker Robbins
alongside like all these Iron Man guys
now the fight is not supremely drawn-out
and so one of the things that ends up
happening when Parker Robbins goes to
attack Doctor Doom what he does is kind
of undo what it was that Reed Richards
did in terms of fixing his face and go
back to scarring his face again now this
really looks to set the stage for like
Doctor Doom going back to his classic
outfit now how you do that I don't
really know because dr. Doom's face was
fixed by the powers beyonders these nine
omnipotent you know multiversal beings
that destroyed the cosmic entity Jie but
once the whole conflict is basically you
know once it ends once it all comes
crashing down then what you end up
having is Ruby Williams who's
essentially kind of taken under the wing
I guess again by Tony Stark as well as
James Rhodes who comes back as war
machine and then it's just kind of like
what comes next that's really sort of
the the question that's being that's
lingering here is what's gonna happen
after this now of course also dr. Doom's
face is all scarred to pieces so again
this whole idea that he's going to go
back and turn you know turn into you
know Victor Von Doom again especially
because of the fact that he's
essentially rebuilding Latveria sending
things back to rights returning to the
role that he's supposed to be again it's
very much bindus kind of you know
wrapping up these loose ends from the
story as it's existed since the
beginning of all-new all-different
marvel running up to the modern day as
well as bringing dr. doom back to the
original Doctor Doom so again it's one
of these things where model setting
things back to the classic way you know
so the way that they used to be the way
that they've been doing it for 60 years
going back to the same old thing so you
know it's kind of got a mixed reaction
for me as somebody who's been reading
comics for so long it's the same old
thing I've been seen before which
actually takes me away from being
interested in it but for the new person
it's all new to them it's they you know
it's all like I've never seen anything
like this before so it's kind of a
it's it's fresh stuff for all of them
for all you new guys so you know I'm
kind of curious okay what's your uh
what's your all's take on this like are
you guys in favor of like the new
direction of things telling new stories
that we haven't seen before or you guys
in favor of the classic things and just
kind of rehashing older stories in
different ways but that being said we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
light and I will catch you all later
purse
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]